[Music]
well it probably comes as no surprise to
you that las vegas is booming every day
new businesses are coming to our
neighborhoods and today we are zooming
in on the area of cactus and southern
highlands west of i-15 sally jaramillo
shares some new options for people in
that area
as southern highlands grows we have a
lot of new construction around us
especially along cactus and our cactus
freeway exit has expanded kaori nagao is
the managing partner of mama bird's
southern kitchen and says this is a
popular area to set up a shop it has
transformed and i'm really excited that
we have so many more options for family
and friends because we didn't have these
local restaurants when they first moved
here from housing to restaurants and
even commercial real estate the cactus
southern highlands decatur area is
seeing it all mr chi boba manager t
kendall in alvaradi likes the location
as businesses support each other we're
seeing a lot more tourists come by i'm
seeing a lot more people from
around the state and businesses in the
southwest area say they're excited for
all the change that's coming their way
and there's no stopping in sight we are
just launching this new expansion we're
doubling in size nagal says customers
have always asked for more seating they
now have 80 seats and are expanding
hours dana berggren owns the coupe
co-working space which recently opened
near russell and decatur the southwest
part of the valley has always been
important for people to have a presence
because it's the halfway point between
henderson and summerlin sally caramillo
live local now
we reached out to commissioner justin
jones who's in charge of that area he
says quote small businesses are the
backbone of our economy they create jobs
and make our neighborhoods more vibrant
i am excited to welcome a diverse mix of
new businesses to the southwest valley
and look forward to working with them